when I was a baby in college that was a
baby with its own listen you might not
like it no that was a baby let me tell
you something what you ended was a
unique genetic code that had eye color
hair color how tall would be how much it
would weigh its personality proclivity
toward mental illness what kind of hair
pattern to male pattern baldness when
you prefer when you had that abortion
performed you eliminated all of that
that's a scientific fact time for the
latest installment of changed my mind
where we rationalize our positions on
controversial issues now given the
recent news we decided to revisit
abortion in this go around a lot of
notable interactions took place quick
question for all the women of all of
those women that have their hands raised
which one of you would rather be forced
to carry an unwanted pregnancy to term
so it's like once they get pregnant and
it's just like damn now it's like I'm
not chilling right now it's like I say
take a culture of your skin cells off
yeah and I could be like oh that's a
human because that's a culture of
growing so nope do like right here the
baby's not ready to go out to the world
and like chill you know like they're not
reading about you but you feel with this
the baby's not ready to go out and chill
I'm gonna guess your two years in
college right now effectively it is a
parasitic relationship between a fetus
and a woman yeah starting philosophy
okay there you go as per usual comment
below your opinions on abortion in the
current laws along with which topics
you'd want to see most discussed for
future installments of course if you
want to keep these coming and ensure
that long-form conversation like these
continue join mug club at laden with
greater calm slash mug club and we'll
actually have another installment with
multiple conversations uploaded soon but
I wanted to give one particular
interview its own attention in this
episode because of all the change my
mind segments we've conducted this one
became the most intensely person by area
meet Yara
people were hyping my nerves in there oh
really what's your name
you're on Steven nice to meet you okay
Yara for this I just no personal I
appreciate that thank you very much
thank you very much and he just said you
have to calm yourself down because
people were hyping your nerves okay what
do you were hoping there were some you
know it's the legality of we can't
really get people water we get them they
go they point to me you know so it seems
like you're upset obviously this is a
sign is pretty clear I'm pro-life you've
been listening some conversations if you
disagree with my position you're welcome
to change my mind they see need to calm
your nerves what do you what are you so
upset about one thing that definitely
really strikes a chord with me is the
fact that a majority of women who have
actually had to face the choice of
abortion it is because it was either
necessary it was medically necessary or
it was just a decision that really was
the fork in the road of your future and
from my understanding a majority of men
I understand they pay child support I
understand that a man is half what it
takes to create a child but when you
weren't by yourself and you are alone
and it is dark and you have to face do I
lose my future like do I throw away my
education I can go back yeah you always
say I can go back but that's twice as
hard raising a child by yourself I
watched my mom as a single mother and I
don't want that life for myself and
abortion itself it's a right I
understand the legalities behind the
late abortion and I do not support it
unless it is medically necessary okay
in terms of it would kill the mother the
fetus is no longer on to a few different
things
yeah um first off I appreciate you being
so forthcoming with your personal story
you didn't have to do that so I do
appreciate you
a lot of people are not willing to talk
about it well thank you very much I'm as
far as yourself if you don't want to be
a single mother go through that life
don't have sex use contraception see I'm
not against choice I believe there are
four choices mm-hmm abstinence
contraception motherhood adoption I'm
just against the hold on one second I'm
just against the one that involves
killing another human being and I think
it's very important here to go back to
the very first thing that you said which
was most abortions are medically
necessary or and they said or it's a
fork in the road in determining your
future conflating those I think it's
pivotal because most abortions performed
are not medically necessary you're right
with a second half most are performed
because the mother at that point doesn't
want to deal with the consequences of
her previous actions can I pause you
right there real quick we're going back
to the four choices that you just said
mm-hmm abstinence which right now let's
realistically look at the rates of teen
sexual activity that's not happening and
especially now hold on in this state we
do not recognize sex education for what
it is we decide to teach abstinence
instead of safe sex and that's been
proven to not work contraceptives birth
control is a hormone it will it will
change my hormone balance it physically
changes my body and in some cases it can
do more harm than good there are some
women who can't take it who can't handle
it and yes I understand there's adoption
as well well while we're doing by the
way with abstinence it is a choice I was
a student until I got married well just
just because it's rare doesn't mean that
it's not at issue let me finish just
because it's rare doesn't mean that's
not a decision contraception isn't only
hold on one second contraception doesn't
involve only hormonal birth control it
also involves a 50 cent rubber that you
could get at a truck stop you're right
it's not a hundred percent and every
time you engage in sexual intercourse
you know that you are engaging in an
activity that could lead to a baby
I understand that but then there's also
the fact and I'm saying motherhood
adoption you can continue with those
well I mean if you want to get into
adoption let's look at the let's look at
the thousands of babies who are in the
foster program right now I mean I
understand not having late-term
abortions unless it's medically
unnecessary but my whole my whole point
is women who are pro-choice make this
decision and anybody who wants to argue
on a religious basis at the end of the
day I haven't not you not you I'm just
saying a majority like not a majority a
portion of people who do want to make
that religious or they're not here
that's irrelevant so let's just talk
about that the science well then in that
case well on adoption let's go back to
that adoption so those children are
still in the foster care program right
now theoretically speaking let's say
abortion was completely odd taken away
mm-hmm what happens with the influx of
births that are gonna occur what's gonna
happen with a women who don't want those
children who initially didn't want that
child and you give them up for adoption
and we have a huge surplus of more
children in the foster care program who
then will not be adopted just as the
many thousands that are in it right now
so can I answer that it sounds to me
first up like a lot of uh solvent of
responsibility but just because someone
is a burden is that is that how we place
value in human life if someone is more
burden sin because their unwanted they
are not bad no no no I want to I want to
determine what let's I'm saying like in
a sense of burdening yeah we don't want
to take the burden I know it's a
different topic but it's just something
someone we don't want to take the burden
of some of our mistakes on a day to day
basis but yet it's not as polar-opposite
as this right now as in the sense of
like I can't bring up other topics
because then we're gonna get off topic
yeah we're absolving women both women
and men by the way I don't know if you
consider yourself oh sorry feminist at
all or but I certainly wouldn't let I
certainly wouldn't let men off the hook
as you are right here listen both women
and men have a responsibility to either
be abstinent use proper contraception
its 2018 I don't believe for a second
that people are not aware of the
contraception methods available to them
and then also be parents
for adoption and there are plenty of
services out there
it sounds like absolving people from a
lot of responsibilities and again none
of this is okay if it's a human life
some of those governments not a toy like
[ __ ] help deter women from wanting to
have an abortion are not as easily
acceptable as everybody thinks that they
are just because you make a certain
amount of money per year means that you
don't qualify for the government aid the
healthcare programs that are available
you don't I don't qualify for them I
slip through the cracks
because I'm right in the middle so
because I had nobody to help me and yes
I can be in another another person on
government subsidies as well as my child
but do you really want to pay if you
have a child I don't have a child I'm
saying theoretically okay do you want to
pay for my subsidies that I need
requiring I would be requiring from the
government no of course not you don't
know no can I know where this is going
down we're going to go and say well
you're not really pro-life unless you
support insert socialized program here
in says I'm pretty consistent across the
board i'm pro-life meaning you cannot
kill another human being inside the womb
or outside of the womb so I think the
pivotal question becomes you talk about
the choice the choice the choice now we
provided four choices you just believe
that it's you believe it's a human right
to provide a fifth choice so in that
case um it's I think it's very important
for you to I guess explained to me why
that's not a human life no I think well
hold on a second
doesn't that matter doesn't it isn't the
most important question if you are
potentially killing a human being only
continue on I will answer that question
but let me continue on this logic trail
here if you are advocating for abortion
and we both acknowledge that it could be
potentially ending a human life isn't it
important for you to be able to pray
it's night and human life only when the
government says that we can it's not ok
to end human life against against what
the army does every day listen we're
talking about Waratah no we're talking
about Wars and we're talking about
self-defense millions killing an
innocent child killing an innocent chef
do you are you ok let me ask you this
you approve of that
no I don't know ok so then you wouldn't
approve of it happening in a womb
correct I don't so you saying that a
child in a womb is gonna be the de facto
of what happens in my life because if I
decide to be if I appreciate I don't
appreciate a person killing another
human being so it does I get that you
say I don't want listen I don't want you
to have a say in my life but I don't I
don't want to have a say in your life I
only wanna have a imagine the legalities
of the laws that I live the laws that
affect me and the millions of other
women that have to have the abortion
because let me tell you right now half a
lot of a lot of hot light have to have
half have to have the abortion so you
only support abortion if it's medically
necessary no I didn't say that ok what
do you mean have to have the abortion
that as in it's a choice if I don't have
the abortion then I have to quit school
I have to have it I have to there's no
choice
I don't you there is no choice whenever
it comes to sitting there and weighing
your options and actually having to
carry to term and deal with the already
extreme changes that happen in your body
like until you have physically carried
something in you until you have had to
face the decision I'm not saying it's
something that's beautiful I'm not
saying that people are out here having
tea parties and getting an abortion
afterwards no it's not pretty something
are they were doing to shout your
abortion campaign it's yeah it's the
really ugly truth of what we had to do
what we had to do there's plenty of
other men in history who will say those
same words we had to do what we had to
do whether it be pretty or not I can
understand the moral obligations that
you feel no not feel and well that we
all have in world no we all have more
obligation not kill other people against
their will period it's not debatable
will because they don't have a thought
process they haven't learned they
haven't they haven't been born and you
know what about a baby they've never
learned brain dead those those who say
that I like the law says that a fetus is
not a baby until it is viable outside of
the womb okay
those those same laws and regulations
that still constitute someone to be
charged with murder or even what
manslaughter if there was an accident
difference between those should be and
what's the moral something can be legal
and entirely immoral okay and there is
no who does it benefit though benefiting
okay a good example would be lets say
slave owners it was legal at one point
and it benefited slave owners right they
could concern about Commission they
could control the bodies of other human
beings abortion only benefits the people
who are killing other lives often out of
convenience it certainly is harmful to
the baby inside of the wounds right do
you think it's very important here for
you to define what constitutes a human
life why is that baby let's say in the
womb says it seems free your definition
is viability what constitutes a human
life
when is it okay when the child is viable
outside of the womb and that does not
happen okay when's that until about five
to six months pregnancy so we've already
talked about late term abortions occur
in the third trimester I believe if you
cut that baby for six months of the damn
baby finger against late term abortion
yes if it's in you know women who do
have leaked term abortions they're not
out here walking around at eight months
pregnant saying oh you know what I don't
feel like having this baby anymore let's
just get rid of it sure they are no
they're not that's almost all late term
abortions
there are medically induced and this is
no not a majority
well whatever ones matter of fact nearly
never nearly never as a late-term
abortion those are not what I support
okay so you would be against late term
abortions if it's not medically
necessary yes sure okay so you would be
against most like to remember yes okay
so you understand all I've survived
abortion infant protection act that just
was presented and all major Democratic
presidential candidates voted against so
here only for thinking this book that
sounds like they might find some some
common ground here this is a bill
proposed for babies whose survivable
terms what term where they aborted at
what point well no this is about all
babies who survived abortions whether
they'll a later term or what point are
these children's you can read it right
here what it basically requires is that
doctors simply provide the same kind of
medical care to born babies from
survived abortions as born babies who
didn't survive attempted abortions every
major DNC candidate voted against that
protection what would you say to them
does that make it moral no that's not in
the sense of like moralities when it
comes to having the abortion in general
you're talking about saving a child who
did actually survive survive an abortion
I'm not in that point yeah you do how
about common ground but what we're
talking about today is the initial
access of abortions and women who need
that sure because you've not convinced
me that women need them certainly they
don't need them they don't need to kill
another human you may not feel like they
need them you know what I'm prospering
I'm actually out here I'm creating a
life for myself and I'm hoping to make a
future for myself and other women are in
the same page as I am are you saying
that you've had an abortion as though
you're saying I'm not going to say that
publicly because they just came and said
I'm well you just said I'm prospering
you just brought up abortion so I'm
confused as betrayal what is that yeah I
did okay you know what I had to sit in
my chair
and I had to face the facts but guess
what I was doing was something that was
going to change my future and it did
because I was left alone always loved to
pay for
I did not qualify for any kind of
funding or payments that people say sure
exists and you will everybody who wants
to say I would have adopted your baby
I'm sorry but go adopt the other 4,000
that are already in foster care programs
here and you can't just because not
everyone here would adopt that baby
doesn't mean it's justifiably killed it
doesn't mean that it was just a five we
meant to force me to have a baby no
one's forcing and have a baby you would
if you took away the law no you no one
be forcing you to have it they would
simply be forbidding you from killing it
no you would be forcing no no one's
forcing it have a baby the only forcible
I want every single how many single
women how many single parents were women
are in poverty do you know the
percentage it could not be less relevant
mm-hmm how is that less relevant because
because Oldman I'm gonna tell you from a
person well you just asked me but then
you said I'm gonna tell you did you want
to ask me yeah okay do you know that it
could not be less relevant because
you're not justified in killing somebody
based on poverty income race sex gender
period it's never justified it's
hilarious because a lot of our
politicians have justifiably killed
other people for Less really hmm yeah
well okay I I can't speak for all
politicians but to go to your argument I
don't believe you're justified in
killing someone because of a lower
income level I feel like I'm justified
in saving myself from having to be
forced into that lower income level just
because I don't have the accesses of
other women who are able to short what
have a husband to support them have the
ability to pay the 15,000 plus dollars
in medical because it's hard to go back
it's hard to go back when have a baby
look at time I'm going back to school
it's really hard to get yeah in order to
get educated it's hard to even support
yourself it's hard to breathe right now
as it is it's hard to go back in these
land and there's fun during that though
that baby doesn't get to go back that
baby was never alive it wasn't until I
was a baby with its own listen you might
not like know that was a baby let me
tell you something what you ended was a
unique genetic code that had eye color
hair color how tall would be how much it
would weigh its personality for clippety
toward mental illness what kind of hair
pattern to male pattern
when you perform when you had that
abortion performed you eliminated all of
that that's a scientific fact the fact
is is that it was a choice and it was
something that had to be done because
regardless of if it's ugly it was
medically necessary if no even if it's
not especially when it's only six weeks
and you know the heartbeat laud you're
familiar correct for a heartbeat law now
it's not really good assistant it's not
really consistent across the board does
he seem Texas seeking abortions acupoint
no I believe that life begins at
conception you believe that life begins
at conception see I believe that life
begins when the child is with viable
outside of the womb with in the third
trimester
so you just said viable but you pointed
at ten weeks I didn't technically point
out something you're just trying to get
very technical I just was no I think
it's important where's the baby viable
broad aspect I'm not a doctor and I'm
not a scientist so I'm not going to say
that on record and sit here and make
myself look ignorant
whenever you're probably ready when I
paired with the facts let me just have I
wasn't prepared for this
okay I appreciate it let me ask you this
this is an important question a human
being alive today are they worth more
than a human being alive 200 years ago I
don't know I don't believe so I'm asking
you you don't believe so no I don't
believe their life is worth more than a
human being born 50 years ago 100 years
ago 200 years ago okay I believe a human
life is intrinsically valuable and right
well right now we're talking with two 25
year olds but a human being 25 years old
20 18 25 years old in the year 1918
would we agree would you place more
value on one person in a certain point
in time than the other person okay let's
go a step further I don't believe that a
wealthy white male on the Upper East
Side of Manhattan I don't believe that
his life is worth any more than a poor
black females in Louisiana would we
agree
but you know what the way that the law
is I would agree but okay well this is
important you're using your using a
theory because technically look how it
works I'm aware the Manhattan man does
actually value because he has more money
in his pocket well he does according out
he does according to you know according
to the law and according to you here's
why because he can pay that I know you
said that you're not prepared and so you
don't mean to present the facts but
you're going to have to allow me to do
so at some point it's not necessarily I
don't want you to present the facts it's
the fact that I want you to recognize
that there are other people that do
actually have an opposing opinion other
than yours then don't believe that life
does could begin at conception that's
why I'm here I recognize your opinion
I've recognized you have an opinion and
I recognize you have a right to an
opinion I believe it's wrong that's fine
so let me present my opinion so you
fully understand it you use viability as
a measurement for human being there are
a lot of parameters there that can
change it now the reason I bring up
someone in the Upper East Side versus
poor person in Louisiana is with the
modern innovations in technology and
science particular medical innovations
you can have a baby that's completely
viable in Manhattan and that exact same
baby that exact same length along and
the pregnancy is not viable and let's
say the hills of West Virginia are in
Louisiana because I like this the same
medical care is one baby of life in one
isn't if a baby survives because it's
born in Lenox Hill in Manhattan at 21
weeks and that same baby dies in
Louisiana one is a life one is a human
life and one's not well are you saying
you're trying to nobody is not sick you
trying to link viability to worth no you
just said that by abilities with the
terminus human life mmm-hmm what I'm
saying is that's not consistent so does
that mean that a human life the value of
a life is different in New York in the
city meaning let's say location is
determined by ability
no time determines liability no what I'm
saying is the exact same time a baby
let's say 22 weeks along in New York and
the greatest Hospital in the country
that same baby 22 weeks along in the
Bayou in Louisiana one lives at 22 weeks
one doesn't because of modern medical
care one is viable one is not you
believe that that's a consistent
measurement of the value of human life I
mean is it viable viability is the
determination on if it's alive so then
no no so it's not viable if it dies at
22 weeks and one location where there
doesn't matter its geographical location
so you're sort of so in your view people
who come from a privileged upper class
with better access to medical care worth
more as human beings certainly and
that's the way our system is set up and
I think it should be changed you you
just you know shrunk away but that's the
truth I'm sorry but the person who can
afford the middle forward the only
difference here is there's one of us
thank your dinner talk about changing
the system I'm saying we need a system
that recognizes human life both
Louisiana's the fact wired that ask
yourself why are these women feeling as
though they need one why do these women
feel as though they can't take care of a
baby cuz I can tell you right now if I
had the perfect job the perfect husband
perfect life I definitely would have had
a baby I tell you what I sure we don't
have any of those things but I wouldn't
feel justified in killing another human
being oh well there you have it what do
you think let me know below are you
pro-life pro-choice is a determinant by
socioeconomic status ethnic minority
status of where life begins let me know
and stay tuned for part two of this
edition of on pro-life
changed my mind hey there if you like
this video this is the part where I
would usually tell you to subscribe but
I can't do it anymore I'm gonna tell you
to subscribe and then YouTube is going
to decide that we can't reach you even
though you subscribe to this channel and
then I'll say hit the notification bell
and then the notification Bell won't
even be there anymore
I don't know what to say more than
likely you'll find my face in a milk
carton but do what you can to stop it
it's
it's just it probably won't do much